(rock music plays)
(rock music fades)
(electric guitar strums)
(crowd cheers)
(electric guitar strums continuously)
(Kelly screams)
- Yeah!
(kelly claps)
(electric guitar strums continuously)
(crowd cheering)
All right everybody, welcome
back to another Rad Mom Hour.
That was a hell of a
sustain on that guitar.
I'm just saying it was nice. It was nice
With your shirt undone, looking good.
We've got Derek Smalls of Spinal Tap,
sitting in with the band y'all.
(crowd cheering)
And Rad Mom Zooey
Deschanel is here because,
those two themes naturally go together.
So, that's what we're doing.
So Zooey, do you and
Jonathan go over the top
whenever you're decorating for Christmas?
I go over the top for
like Christmas and stuff.
- Yeah. We, we like to
decorate. Yeah. Yeah.
Especially Jonathan like
loves Christmas decorations.
I love Christmas. So we get
into the Christmas thing
and like Halloween and stuff like that.
- Oh, me too. Our kids
are around the same age,
yours are four and six, right?
And do they freak out that you're like,
a part of like one of the-
Like it's hard to make another
Christmas classic film,
and Elf is like one of
the greatest films ever.
(crowd cheering) - Thank you.
They've never seen it.
- What?
- They've only seen one
movie that I've done
and that was um Trolls.
- Oh, yeah!
I did Trolls World Tour.
- Right, right, right, yeah.
So, I was in Trolls
and they've seen that
like a thousand times.
So they just think I'm a
voice actor. (crowd laughing)
Yeah, and then I did
music for Winnie the Pooh
and they saw that too, so
they just think I do like,
like music and stuff for animated movies.
They don't like have any idea.
- That's kind of awesome.
- They kind of know, but
they really don't, like
if somebody comes up to me,
they're like, "Why is that
person talking to you?"
I'm like, "Oh, um, I don't know.
They're like asking me directions"
- And you don't know
how to play it off, yeah
- I just yeah, like I kind of, yeah.
I don't want to be like, yeah.
- Well people know me.
- Yeah, people know who I am.
- Did you, I always wonder because
people ask me this about songs and
you have albums out as well,
which, I love your albums, (indistinct).
But anyway, but do you ever,
do you ever want, like,
do you ever know, oh, that's going to be,
that's going to hit, like,
cause did you know Elf
was going to be like,
hugely popular?
- I actually feel like, I know,
like reading a, I feel like with comedies,
like, if I laugh out loud
while reading a script,
that's a pretty darn good sign.
I remember sitting,
like I was only
21 when I made that
movie. I remember sitting,
I was at my parents'
house, Cause I basically
just dropped out of college,
(crowd laughing)
to be an actor,
um and I remember sitting
at my parents' house,
like reading that script and
being, and laughing out loud.
And at that, like since then
I've seen that that's a good sign.
- Oh my God. It's just one
of my favorite things ever.
I never thought I'd
watch something as much
as I watched White Christmas
- I mean Will Ferrell, is just so,
perfect,
in that movie.
- It's amazing. Your
comedic timing is amazing.
Let's not be too humble.
(crowd cheering)
But, are you still performing?
Like you and She & Him?
I didn't know cause like,
the people have been on like
COVID lockdown, whatever.
- Yeah, I mean, we
didn't go out last year.
For a good reason, but we're going out,
we're doing a little Christmas tour.
- Oh. So good.
- So, that will be fun.
- And your sound is so
perfect for Christmas,
that's what I love about you.
- I love Christmas music, so
- I love it. Anyway, so you,
you've become a crusader for
clean and healthy living.
And I would, I was going to ask like,
when did that become so important to you?
But I feel like every time
you're pregnant, like,
cause I've been pregnant twice,
and I never really thought about stuff,
until I was pregnant. I was like,
I'm responsible for these humans.
- So is that when it happened for you.
- Exactly when it happened.
I mean, like before that, you're like,
yeah, it's fine if I eat, you know,
something that, you know, whatever
is made of plastic or,
- This is gonna kill me.
- It's fine. But when you have like,
when you're like carrying a child, like
it's so much responsibility.
It's like such a heavy weight like that,
that I ended up doing a bunch of,
I never would have pictured
this necessarily, but I,
I really started looking
into the like food system
and kind of how messed up it is.
Um, when I, when I was pregnant,
just realizing that like, okay, you know,
I have the resources to go and like
buy healthy food and everything and
not everybody has access
to it. So I, at that time,
I started a company called Let Us Grow.
Um, we do like hydroponic
uh gardens that are,
you can grow on a balcony and it uses 95%,
less water than traditional,
like in-ground garden.
- That's amazing.
- And then just this last year,
I co-founded a company called Merryfield,
and it's kind of like couponing,
but like for if you're lazy, you know,
because I was, I was like couponing,
And when, you know, you go to the store
and they're like, do you have any coupons?
And I'm like,
like I saw the coupon the
last time I came here,
and it was like on the back and
you have to be like good
at math and everything.
This is just, you can go to any store,
take a picture of your receipt,
it'll, like, log in all of
the participating brands.
It's like a little computer thing.
- That's awesome.
- I don't know how it works, but,
- Yeah. (crowd laughing)
- It does.
- Yeah, obviously we both need
the apps. So we don't know-
- Exactly
- That's awesome though.
- I'm not an app developer, but
- It's brilliant though.
- So it's really cool and
you can shop like anywhere.
So you know, like a lot
of times you have a coupon
for a specific store, you
have to go to that store
and it's like, you have to go to like
a million stores to buy things.
This one, you can go wherever you shop.
And if like the brand is one
of our participating brands,
you get 5% back or more.
- I love that.